look at where we are we're in auradon
you're an inspiration Sophia Carson you
always believe in yourself and push
yourself to the limit Wonder Girl Wonder
your songs are beautiful your dance
moves are on points and your acting
skills are beyond perfection we couldn't
imagine anyone else to fill evey shoes
which is why you're one of our favorite
descendants stars of all time clearly
you were born for the limelight the
stars of descendants theory are beyond
talented which is why we aren't
surprised that there are knee-deep in
new and exciting projects watch until
the end to find out who the busiest
dissident star is it might just be the
person you least expect let's get
started
and a cat cards anime only be 16 years
old but the girl's on fire she gave us
the dizzy germain we all deserved when
she joined the descendents cast for its
second and third installments but
despite descendants three wrapping up in
2019 and his acting career is just
getting started in 2019 Anna starred as
agent Olympia on odd squad she also
starred as Zoe on spring break away and
Zoe Valentine but what fans are most
excited about is the upcoming sequel to
all the boys PS I still love you
the sequel is set to hit the small
screen sometime in 2020 Thomas Doherty
Thomas Doherty is the 24-year old
Scottish actor who stole our heart says
Harry hook in descendants two and three
since wrapping up production Thomas has
landed the role of Peters avid offski on
the TV series Catherine the Great
but Thomas is diehard fans are most
excited to see him rise as the vampire
Sebastian on the second season of
legacies Thomas is also starring as Liam
in the upcoming TV series high fidelity
Sarah Jeffery princess Audrey Canadian
actress Sarah Jeffrey might be known as
the queen of mean but in real life she's
nothing of the sorts Sarah played the
role of Maggie Veera on the TV series
Charmed from 2018 to 2019 on top of that
Sarah just completed filming the short
movie Dahlia which is set to come out in
2019 Sarah isn't currently cast in any
upcoming productions so if the
Karson my mom's queen which makes me a
princess
is there anyone more beautiful fabulous
and talented than Sophia Carson yeah we
didn't think so
ever since leaving the Disney Channel
Sophia has been pulling out all the
stops she starred as Ava Jalali on the
spin-off show Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionist and now she's currently
filming the upcoming movie feel the
beads Sophia will star as April a
performer who returns to her hometown to
recruit and train dancers for
competition after failing to succeed on
Broadway keine and McClain Chyna and
McClain has got talent for days and
she's not afraid to use it
she rose to fame after starring as uma
in descendants 2 & 3
shortly after China snagged the role of
Jennifer Pierce aka lightning on the hit
TV series Black Lightning China has
recently been cast in the movie QB
Halloween she will be co-starring with
legendary actors like Adam Sandler Rob
Schneider and Kevin James yeah I really
enjoy Mitchell Hope King Ben may have
stolen nas heart and descendants but
he's about to steal someone else's heart
this Christmas season
Mitchell's role has yet to be revealed
but he's all set to star in the upcoming
film let it snow
alongside Isabella moaner who is known
for playing Dora Endor and the lost city
of gold Jedediah Goodacre
hi I'm Jedediah Goodacre Jedediah did an
amazing job of portraying the
self-absorbed son of Cinderella and
Prince Charming in descendants three but
playing chad is just one of jedediah's
many accomplishments he plays Dorian
Gray on the Netflix original series
chilling Adventures of Sabrina as well
as Roman on legacies keep an eye out for
him in the short film hunters cabin as
well as the movie there you'll find me
so uh now that was a really cool thing I
thought Branagh DMing Co the gorgeous
Brenna Domingo is a star through and
through we loved her as the sweet and
innocent Jane from Disney's descendants
Brina has been cast in two upcoming
productions she set the star as Liz in
the never list and Maya in Saturday at
the starlight Cheyenne Jackson Cheyenne
Jackson is the acclaimed actor who
starred as mouths dad Hades in
descendants three he's known for playing
various roles on American Horror Story
on top of being a celebrated Broadway
sensation Cheyenne has recently finished
filming the TV series stellar people in
which he plays the role of a handsome
cop hey everybody here booboo Stewart
it looks like booboo is the busiest
ascendant star out of the bunch
he's been cast in eleven different
productions since leaving the Disney
Channel he'll be starring as Vic Lakota
in Paradise City and as Peter drags wolf
in let him go boo boo was all set to
becoming one of the biggest stars of
2020 dove Cameron dove Cameron is one of
the biggest stars in the world
she's a Broadway Queen a seasoned
actress and an all-around triple threat
dove isn't currently cast in any movies
or TV shows but that's just because
she's focusing on her music career she
just came out with two new singles
bloodshot and waist and she couldn't be
any more excited for the future which
upcoming projects are you most excited
to see tell us in the comments find out
what the cast of descendants three is
currently working on and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the bangs thanks for
watching we'll see you again soon
[Music]